結構長い期間もこのように住んでますこのの賃貸南で大家さんできた今その他てもと
管理している人にこのように住んで僕も2年か3年くらいなんですけど多分
史上最強に迷惑かけてるなと思っております本当申し訳なさがハンパないんですけど
ほんと特に今年ですね今年はもう何なんか
超中学生が家に来て叫んだりは今日案内もたくさん送られてきたりそしても最後には
ストーカーが来たり撮影高木たりしてすごい迷惑をかけたんで本当に僕とモコ年に行っ
ちゃダメなんじゃねーかくらいに思ってましてその中大谷さんに
呼び出しを食らいました
入っていきます矢原ちゃダメなんだよ本当になんなんだろどうなるんだろう
結構よ入ってきます
ん
ブーバーし
それで連れします
[音楽]
oh
します
re
するん
はいお疲れ様です
無償ッ
さ一体
あ年始にコンサートあるって言ったじゃんあっ派の奴とちょっとした
あっよかったーー通話であれだ野菜から色々あってあとはー
なんだよこれ別に済みましただけで超せっかく
ちょっと大家さんとお話できるっタイミングがきそうなんで順次に僕がちょっと気に
なってること
あっを弾いてもいいですか
ハーイ位
ブーッ
だめだかあなたまって緊張しますかいつも雑談したしてるんですよ
adai 今年も一年ありがとうございますこ仕事は根強いですか
もう断念上下っていうものが入ってもう3年3年くらい
いやもっとか3年以上ですよね以上ですね
夜中 a せっかくこの機会がないとか聞いてみたいんですけど
今年結構色々あったじゃないですかはぁ
めちゃ腐しれた荷物届けられたり中学生がこう叫んだりする中でどうかが来たでてい
ます
後方を大家さんにご迷惑をおかけしてるんじゃないかなっていうすごい心配が家へ動い
ただけにあの言葉選ばないといけないんですけれどあの全然か積もっ
今年さようなあの ok
楽しませていただきました
昆布ですはい
事前にありましたでしょ防犯カメラあぁそうですね
ああの防犯カメラ湯につけたって言ったんですけどあれも多いさんと相談そうそれ
じゃああの家全然描けです
本当ですか
というのはあの1万個も2万金をマンションを経営しているわけではないので
そうすると最大公約数を全く音止めてないので
特徴なるものを作って浮気なのでそこがすごい心配していたし
ずーかそこが結構堪えるところで
ここ家でいろいろドンちゃんさぁやってるわけじゃないんですよ
そういうのを見るとなんか色々他の大家さんとかだと
ユーチューバーを入れた気ないみたいな人もたまにいるみたいで
他のユーチューバーからそういう形街君ですよ多少どんちゃん様に行っても隣に
まったく影響のない作りをしますそうなんですよ
そこがすごいつつありません何も大丈夫です
あざっ本当に今年でいろいろあったんで
いろんな方にご迷惑おかけしつつも
僕が一番
ご迷惑おかけした長尾屋さんなのかなっていうと思いマジであの楽しめます
う
そういっていただけるだけで一さんの知らないところでケアができればなと思っ
ドップ再建小学生少なくなりましたよ
ブービー生きてはもう
カーン to do 結構パキッに
違うオヤジだと一緒だよあっはぁ
気持ち寄せたかったなっていうところがいい
それ一度取ると大変えっ
あ
だからさもう一度コイ通り粒でるからことですね
ドッキリとかってどうですかいるよほんとですかん
くっきりいって末永くねほんとらこそというこの素晴らしい建物と大家さんのか
人の良さであっ本当に僕パス買ってるんだより
今後ともよろしくお願いでなく他の人の良さは修羅場の数ですはっはっはよろしくねご
視聴ありがとうございますありがとうございます
[音楽]
me
バッハ
間もよろしくお願いございありがとうございます
大江さん成功んはぁ